faire corps ensemble pour combattre le
virus c'est comme ça qu'on pourrait voir
cette méthode d'immunité collective
cette stratégie consiste à développer
suffisamment d'anticorps pour arrêter le
développement de l'épidémie
dès lors que 50 à 60 % de la population
est contaminée
alors sur le papier la proche est plutôt
séduisante mais suscite une difficulté
de taille il faut provoquer dans un
premier temps un nombre importants de
contamination
et qui dit contamination massive dit
rapidement saturation des services de
santé qui doivent traiter les cas les
plus graves
aux prémices de l'épidémie boris johnson
était confiant dans cette méthode
je crois que les mesures en valent la
peine pour ralentir la propagation de la
maladie
pour réduire le pic pour sauver des vies
minimiser la souffrance est donné à
notre service de santé la chance de
faire face dix jours plus tard rattrapé
par la perspective de devoir x 30 ses
capacités d'urgence au moins de trois
mois
le premier ministre britannique rentrer
dans le rang boris johnson adopte la
méthode du conte film la suède et les
pays bas eux ont persisté avec ses
principes
revisitez stockholm laisse le libre
arbitre à la population mais les
autorités suédoises préconise comme dans
les pays ayant adopté le confinement le
respect de règles de distanciation
sociale et incite aussi à limiter les
déplacements
une stratégie totalement assumée par le
gouvernement
je dirais tout d'abord qu'il n'y a pas
de stratégie suédois spécifiques
nous avons le même objectif que tout
autre pays pour lutter contre la
pandémie
ensuite les différents pays prennent des
mesures différentes en fonction de leurs
traditions de leur manière de gouverner
la société de leur expérience et je suis
sûr que les pays nordiques le fond
chacun avec sa propre expérience
je pense que lorsque vous regardez les
soins de santé la façon dont ils ont
fonctionné en permanence cela plutôt
bien fonctionné je veux dire que nous
avons toujours des places libres soins
intensifs en suède
nous pouvons certainement prendre en
charge plus de personnes si davantage de
personnes se présentent
les autorités suédoises l'assurent ils
pourraient atteindre l'immunité
collective au mois de mai mais le prix à
payer est importante parmi les dix
millions d'habitants on compte plus de
16 mille cas et près de 2000 morts la
suède et le 20e pays le plus touché au
monde en nombre de cas est le
quatorzième pays en nombre de décès des
chiffres qui laissent perplexe et cette
stratégie est loin de faire l'unanimité
dans le pays une vingtaine de chercheurs
ont signé ce mardi une tribune exigent
des mesures rapides et radical parmi
lesquels figure en bonne place la
fermeture des écoles et des restaurants
il y a eu plusieurs appels signé par des
dizaines d'épidémiologistes pour que la
suède adopte des mesures de
distanciation sociale et les fermetures
d'écoles et de commerce comme dans les
autres pays
mais le gouvernement fait la sourde
oreille j'ai moi même signer certains de
ces appels
le gouvernement évoque quelques milliers
de morts mais nos chiffres montrent
qu'on pourrait se retrouver avec des
dizaines de milliers de décès le modèle
le plus pessimiste de l'étude de cet
épidémiologiste prévoit 96 mille morts
beaucoup trop au vu de la population
suédoise pour les hollandais les 1000
été collective et appelé le confinement
intelligent en clair les magasins
peuvent ouvrir s'ils respectent les
distances de sécurité et n'accueille pas
plus de deux personnes à l'intérieur
en revanche les restaurants bars coffee
shops écoles sont fermées jusqu'au 28
avril
les rassemblements sont interdits et une
distance de sécurité d'un mètre et demi
est obligatoire les néerlandais ne
doivent pas justifier leurs déplacements
et le gouvernement compte sur leur auto
discipline ce qui n'a pas du tout été le
cas le week-end dernier et ces derniers
jours ce qui laisse donc encore une fois
perplexe
au vu des chiffres plus de 34000 cas et
près de 4000 décès pour une population
de 17 millions d'habitants
la solution miracle n'existe donc pas et
l'avenir de ces pays est plus
qu'incertain confinement ou pas